good morning Hank it's Wednesday woke up
yesterday at mom and dad's house at 8:30
in the morning to this painting of
zombie me admired the view of Western
North Carolina from the porch and then
decided to go for a walk
heck I guess now is as good a time as
any to tell you that today's video
contains goat sex and I don't mean that
is like some kind of weird euphemism so
yeah be advised so Hank as you know it
is possible to walk for many miles for
mom and dad's house without ever seeing
a person or a house first
I walked up this Ridge and then wound my
way down the ravine towards aunt I'm
about to fall save the camera protip
leaves are slippery anyway I made it
down to the creek eventually and then
bushwhacked my way up the creek bed I'd
walked here the day before with Henry
and explained that the trees had shed
their leaves which had fallen to the
ground and how the dead leaves
eventually become dirt that feed the
still living trees and I was reminded of
Rudolph Virchow famous observation that
all cells come from other cells life
baguettes life it's the realization that
made all the modern biology and disease
treatments possible and yes I'm getting
to the goat sex so if you keep climbing
up the creek bed you could walk four
miles up to the top of the mountain but
as you can hear I was already somewhat
tired so I decided to take the logging
road down to visit mom and dad's goats
Hank as you are well aware mom and dad
raised goats and then turned their milk
into very fancy soap and cheeses but in
order for goats to produce milk they
have to have babies and in order for
that to happen yeah when I arrived at
the goats I immediately saw yes that is
the male goat peeing on his goat beard
and because I have an expert in unusual
animal mating habits I immediately knew
that this was a surefire sign that love
was in the air
lady goats it turns out love a good
pee-stained goateed oh go to II just got
that after the ceremonial peeing on the
beard there was some cuddling and some
tail wagging and the rubbing of the pea
beard across the body of the lady goat
and the whole thing was frankly taking
forever like if this were a Kardashian
reality show I could have stretched my
footage into four episodes wait are
those his oh my god I figured I might be
discouraging them from actually getting
to business so I hit a little
whereupon the guy started humping all
the wrong parts of the lady and then
just as I was about to give up and walk
home success terrifying horrible success
I'm really glad Henry didn't see that
Hank I think he would have had some
questions some ways are more palatable
than others but life finds a way Hank to
make life from life and also to make
life from that which was once alive and
I was so lost and thought about all of
that that pretty soon I became massively
and extraordinarily lost in the woods
I'm extremely lost I have no idea where
I am
oh just don't know where the house is in
relationship to here I'm gonna do the
Boy Scout thing where you follow the
water downhill until you get to a place
or a person that strategy worked out
surprisingly well and eventually I
caught my trail again I knew I was on
the path home and I saw the skid marks
from my fall if I hadn't slipped on
those leaves Hank I don't know how I
ever would have gotten home and so it
was another life was saved by dead
leaves Hank that's the news from the
woods of North Carolina where thanks to
the hot hot action you just saw mom
should have more milk for soap soon I'll
see you on Friday
I'm mostly filming this for posterity if
I die walking across this bridge I just
wanted stated for the record that I
didn't want to walk across the bridge I
just didn't know any other way to get
back to the house come on big money no
whammies yes
back on the road